مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا لليوم السابع على
التوالي تتواصل المظاهرات في محافظات
مصريه مختلفه احتجاجا على تردي الاوضاع
المعيشيه وجوانب اخرى ترى فئات واسعه من
الشعب المصري انها تنغص
حياتها لم يتوقف الامر عندما سماها
الناشطون جمعه الغضب وخرجت مظاهرات جديده
في مناطق من محافظات اسوان والجيزه
والمنيا وهتف المتظاهرون في بعضها ضد
الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي وطالبوا بالحريه
وتوفير الحياه الكريمه
للمصريين يلفت الانتباه في هذه الموجه من
الاحتجاجات في مصر انها تجري في مناطق
فقيره في الغالب من الارياف والبلدات
ومعظم المشاركين فيها شبان لا تحركهم قوى
سياسيه او افكار
ايديولوجيه رصاص حي يطلق لتفريق المحتجين
في قرى مصر وبلداتها يسقط اول قتيل في يوم
الجمعه التي امل بعض المحتجين ان تكون
حاشده لم تكن كذلك لكنها تميزت بان سالت
فيها دماء محتجين في احدى قرى
الجيزه ولم يكن هذا وحده ما جعلها لافته
بل تواصل الاحتجاجات على مدار اسبوع كامل
وازدياد اعداد المتظاهرين والاهم في راي
مراقبين انها خرجت في عمومها من الاطراف
من القرى الجوع وان اغلبها عفوي ولا تقف
وراءه قوه سياسيه او احزاب معارضه وقد سار
فيها من وصفوا باصحاب الجلابيب اي الفقراء
وابناء القرى وكان اغلبهم من الشباب وذلك
مؤشر الى اوضاع معيشيه ضاغطه وبالغه
الصعوبه تعيشها تلك المناطق يحدث هذا وسط
ما يقول مناصر الرئيس السيسي انها اكبر
عمليه تحديث واعاده بناء للبلاد في
تاريخها المعاصر وشمل هذا مح لات لاعاده
تنظيم المدن والتخلص من المباني العشوائيه
والتوسع في بناء الجسور وتحديث البنيه
التحتيه وتجلت تلك السياسه على الارض في
اكبر عمليات هدم تشهدها مصر وتقدر السلطات
عدد المباني المخالفه بنحو مليون و800 الف
مبنى وعقار ومنشاه بما في ذلك المساجد
وشرعت السلطات بالفعل في عمليات الهدم
لكنها سرعان ما اقترحت حلولا ترى انها
وسطى لامتصاص غضب المتضررين على راسها
نظام للتصالح يقوم على ان يدفع صاحب
العقار المخالف مبلغا تحدده السلطات وتلك
جبايه حسب وصف كثيرين تؤكد ان الهدف ليس
وقف المخالفات بل السطو والوصف للمتضررين
على ما تبقى في جووب المواطنين احنا ما
طلعنا احنا محبوسين ا
محبوسين وفقا لمراقبين فانه من الصعب
التكهن بماله ما حدث ويحدث لم تنتقل
الاحتجاجات الى شوارع المدن الكبرى بالنظر
الى القبضه الامنيه والتعامل الخشن مع
المتظاهرين
لا
لا لن اسمح ابدا ان احنا نهد بلدنا ونضعها
كده وحد يتصور ان هو لا والله لو الامر
نزل هخلي الجيش المصري ينزل كل كرهى مصر
وانا بكلمكم عشان تبقوا عارفين يعني هو
وقف ونبقى بدوله مظبوط ياسيب مكاني وامشي
من هنا هل هي ازمه امنيه تحل بنزول الجيش
الى الشوارع يقول كثيرون ان اسباب
الاحتجاجات عديده ولا حل لها بالتشديد
الامني بل بمعالجه اسبابها الكبرى ووفقا
لبيانات البنك الدولي فان معدلات الفقر
اصبحت كارثيه بامتياز فنحو 32% من
المصريين اصبحوا فعليا تحت خط الفقر اي
انهم يعيشون على اقل من 50 دولارا شهريا
وتقدم بيانات المنظمات الدوليه صورا اكثر
قتامه للفقر في البلاد فهو يتوحش في
محافظات الجنوب ومدنه وقراه بحيث يصل الى
نحو
66% في محافظه اسيوط مثلا ونحو 60% في
صهاج واكثر من 50% في الاقصر والمنيا
ويتزامن هذا مع استمرار السلطات في
الاستدانه الخارجيه والانفاق على مشاريع
يقول بعض منتقديها ان بالامكان تاجيلها
الطبقه الوسطى تسح حق وتكاد تختفي في راي
هؤلاء اما البقيه ففق او عرضه للفقر حسب
بيان للبنك الدولي وهذا وسواه يكفي لاخراج
المصريين الى الشارع تعبيرا عن الغضب او
بحثا عن
حلول متابعه لهذا الموضوع ينضم الينا اولا
من الدوحه عبد الفتاح فايد محرر الشؤون
المصريه في قناه الجزيره عبد الفتاح
المظاهرات استؤنفت هذه الليله في اكثر من
منطقه في مصر ماذا في جديدها حتى اللحظه
نعم حسن كما ذكرنا من قبل وتوقعنا انها
ستنطلق في التاسعه بتوقيت القاهره انطلقت
قبل ذلك الموعد حتى بكثير و اتسعت
جغرافيتها كثيرا الملحوظه الاساسيه اليوم
هو ان اتساع مظاهرات جاء في الصعيد اكثر
من ذي قبل اكثر من الايام الماضيه تقريبا
كل محافظات الصعيد صعيد مصر فيها وفي
قراها مظاهرات احتجاجيه من اسوان الى قنا
والاقصر واسيوط وسوهاج والمنيا فكل
محافظات الصعيد تقريبا الان وفقا
لناشطين ومشاركين في هذه المظاهرات فيها
مظاهرات احتجاجيه الى جانب بالتاكيد
الجيزه وايضا الاسماعيليه والشرقيه
وبالتالي هناك اتساع في نطاق النطاق
الجغرافي لهذه المظاهرات الاحتجاجيه ايضا
هذا هو اليوم السابع اسبوع كامل من
المظاهرات الاحتجاجيه لم تتوقف لم توقفها
ال الاجراءات الامنيه المشدده ولا حتى
اعمال العنف ضد المتظاهرين التي كانت
بالامس ولا حملات التشويه وحتى الاستنفار
الديني او استنفار المؤسسات الدينيه
واستنفار ايضا الاعلامي ضد هذه المظاهرات
شيطنت المظاهرات وشيطنته المشاركين فيها
والداعين اليها وتصويرها على انها هدم
للدوله وليست تعبير عن الراي وليست احتجاج
سلمي ضد اجراءات تتخذها السلطه المصريه
يرى كثير من المصريين انها اجراءات قمع
واجراءات ظالمه سواء ما يتعلق منها
بالجوانب الامنيه والجوانب الحقوقيه او ما
يتعلق ايضا بالجوانب المعيشيه نعم حس ا اي
تحدي يمكن ان يشكله انتشار هذه المظاهرات
في مناطق الصعيد بشكل عام بالتاكيد انتشار
المظاهرات في مناطق جغرافيه كثيره
ومتباعده ومتعدده هو يكون يجعلها خارج
نطاق السيطره الامنيه ويجعل امكانيه ان
تلتحم هذه
التجمعات الريفيه مع بعضها البعض وتخرج
الى المدن امرا واردا في مقبل الايام ان
لم تسارع السلطات المصريه بالتاكيد الى
تقديم حلول حقيقيه مرضيه للمحتجين وهم من
بسطاء المصريين ومن فقراء الشعب المصري
الذين يطالبون بالحدود الدنيا وهي بالدفاع
عن مسكنهم يعني لا يطالبون باكثر من ذلك
على الرغم من ان هناك بالتاكيد شعارات
سياسيه ترفع في هذه المظاهرات نتيجه حال
حاله الانسداد السياسي وحاله الاحتقان
السياسي هذا الامر حدث في الجيزه يعني في
الجيزه بدانا نشهد بدات في القرى مثل
الكدايه وغيرها ثم وكفر قنديل وغيرها ثم
بدانا نشهد في بعض الاياء في المدن في مدن
محافظه الجيزه كانت هناك مظاهرات بالامس
في الهرم في نزله السمان في الهرم واليوم
هناك مظاهرات في ترسا بالمنيب وهي من
المناطق الحضاريه وليست المناطق الريفيه
وبالتالي استمرار المظاهرات الاحتجاجيه
حتى وان بدات في المناطق القرويه والريفيه
فانه بالامكان ان تصل الى المناطق
الحضاريه والى المدن نعم حت هل اسلوب
السلطات في مواجهه هذه التظاهرات كان على
المستوى الامني مباشره او على مستوى
محاوله التجاهل في وسائل الاعلام والتخفيف
من اهميه هذه التظاهرات هل لكل
ذلك
يعني هل ذلك يدفع الى مزيد من الغضب
الشعبي بالتاكيد يدفع الى مزيد من الغضب
طالما انه لا تقدم حلول ويستمر الاستهزاء
بالمتظاهرين لاحظ مثلا حسن بان الهاشتاج
الذي يتصدر في مصر اليوم هو مليون تحيه
للجلابيه يعني هي نظرا لحاله السخريه التي
ملات الاعلام المصري وملات بعض الاصوات
المؤيده للنظام من منظر المتظاهرين ومن
انهم من اصحاب الجلاليب والاطفال كما
قالوا وبالتالي كان الرد بانه مليون تحيه
للجلابيه وكانت هناك هنا هناك حملات مضاده
على السوشيال ميديا تفخر بانتسابه
وانتمائها الى الجلابيه والى اصحاب
الجلابيب والى القرى
وبالتالي هذه الحمله الاعلاميه هذا
التشويه الاعلامي ياتي بنتيجه عكسيه
الاستنفار الامني لاعتقالات مئات
المعتقلين لم تاتي بنتيجه وانما جاءت
بنتيجه عكسيه اعمال العنف ضد المتظاهرين
تلقى استهجانا حتى من قبل بعض الاصوات
العاقله داخل النظام والتي تحذر من
امكانيه تكرار سيناريو يناير 2011 في حال
افرطت الشرطه المصريه في استخدام العنف
كذلك استخدام المؤسسات الدينيه هو في
الحقيقه اتى بردود افعال كثيره سلبيه على
هذه المؤسسات الدينيه وتحديدا على الازهر
الشريف الذي كان يحتفظ لنفسه بمسافه بعيده
عن وزاره الاوقاف على سبيل المثال فاذا به
يصطف الان مع وزير الاوقاف في الحديث عن
ان المظاهرات هدم للدوله وبدات بعض
الفيديوهات القديمه لشيخ الاظهر الذي التي
كان يحض فيها على التظاهر ضد الرئيس
الراحل محمد مرسي وتقارن مع المظاهرات
الان التي توصف بانها هدم للدوله نعم حس
شكرا لك عبد الفتاح فايد محرر الشؤون
المصريه في قناه الجزيره وايضا لتسليط
مزيد من الاضواء على مشهد المظاهرات
الجاريه في مصر منذ اسبوع معنا من القاهره
عبر الانترنت اسعد هيكل المحامي والمحلل
السياسي ومن واشنطن الدكتور خليل العناني
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في معهد الدوحه
للدراسات العليا ابدا معك سيد اسعد هيكل
لماذا الاصرار على وصم هؤلاء المتظاهرين
الفقراء بانهم يهدمون الدوله ويهددون
الاستقرار وان جهات خارجيه
تحركهم يعني الحقيقه هذا فيه جزء كبير من
الواقع هذه المظاهرات الدائره حاليا
تذكرنا بمظاهرات المظاهرات الليليه لجماعه
الاخوان المسلمين في نهايه عام 2014 وطوال
عام نهايه عام 2013 وطوال عام
2014 تقريبا الجدير بالذكر ودعني يعني اضع
هذه الملاحظه الهامه انه ليس لم يكن هناك
امس في نزله السمال بالهرم قيمت مظاهرات
هذه مظاهره مبركه اعدت واخرجت عن طريق
شركه اعلاميه مصريه وللاسف وقع فيها كثير
من الاعلاميين حسبما اشار الاستاذ عبد
الفتاح فايد منذ قليب وهذا ليس معناه ان
كل المظاهرات بالطبع ليست مفبركه لكن
بالتاكيد ان هناك بعض الاحتجاجات في بعض
المناطق المتفرقه تستغلها بعض الجماعات
التي تحترف توجيه الخطاب الديني المغلوط
حتى اننا نلظ توجيه بعض الهتافات
تتمسح في الدين وتتهم المخالف لها بالكفر
كما يهتف
المتظاهرين لا اله الا الله مش عارف مين
يسقط عدو الله وبالتالي الامر ابعد في
الحقيقه من هذه المظهرات لانه يعكس في ذات
الوقت الوعي قضيه الوعي في مصر لازالت
لازال المواطن المصري تستطيع الجامعات
الدنيه ان تؤثر
عليه تستل اعتقد سيد سيد اسعد نعم واضح
يعني وض اتضحت اتضحت الفكره لكن اود
الاشاره الى نقطه نحن بالامس تحدثنا اعتقد
عن هذه عن هذه المظاهره التي اشرت اليها
ال انها مفبركه وكان حديثنا واضحا انه
هناك اي يعني بعض المعلومات التي تقول بان
السلطه هي التي قامت السلطات هي التي قامت
بفبركه هذه التظاهر ودسها عبر شبكات
التواصل لتقع فيها وسائل اعلام
معارضه هذا الامر تحدثنا به بالامس على ما
اعتقد نعم بس انا يعني هو لازال حتى اليوم
الاستاذ عبد الفتاح سيد رد بهذا الامر
فاردت ان اشير الى ذلك فقط يعني حتى وهذا
لا يمنع بالتاكيد ان هناك بعض الاحتياجات
لدى بعض قطاعات من المواطنين المتضرره
بالفعل من قانون التصالح الاخير وبعض التض
الاجتماعيه الاخرى لكن علينا ان نستبعد
اطلاقا جماعه الاخوان المسلمين هذه
الاشكاليه السياسيه الكبيره في السياسه
المصريه منذ اكثر طيب اذا كان الامر اذا
كان الامر بهذه الخطوره سيد اسعد اذا كان
الامر بهذه الخطوره والمظاهرات تذكر
بمظاهرات عام
2014 اذا هذا الامر بهذه الخطوره لماذا
هذا الاستهزاء من جانب السلطات دائما
والتخفيف من قدر واهميه هذه المظاهرات في
الوقت الحاضر
يعني بلا مبالغه دعني اقول ان هناك حربا
متبادله بين تنظيم جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
والسلطه اي سلطه بقى حتى مش السلطه
الحاليه منذ 2013 وحتى الان على مستوى
الاعلام هناك حرب متبادله ليس كل بالنسبه
الاعلام المصري في قطاع كبير جدا في
الاعمال المصري تفاعل مع هذه المزهرات ودع
السلطه للاستجابه اليها هناك ايضا حرب
دينيه لعلك تلحظ ان هناك بعض من المحسنين
على جماعه الاخوان خرجوا اليوم يهاجمه
مؤسسه دينيه عريقه واصيله
وجميع المصريين بل العالم كله يحترمها هي
مؤسسه الازهر الشريف على خلفيه بيان دع
فيه المتظاهرين في الحقيقه الى الهدوء
والى عدم الاضرار بالدوله والنظام المصري
والسلام الاجتماعي وهذا لم يكن ابد
بالحديث عن الازهر سيد اسعد سيد اسعد
بالحديث عن الازهر الم يكن غريبا ان لا
يتضمن اي شيء من مطالب هؤلاء المتظاهرين
او معاناتهم او ما يشكون منه بالنسبه
للاوضاع الاقتصاديه او لهدم مساكنهم هو هو
الازهر ليس مؤسسه سياسيه ولا مؤسسه
اجتماعيه هو يرى ويلحظ وعلينا ان نحترم
وجهه نظر الازهر الشريف ونرصد ما يبتغيه
فانه يلحظ ان هناك من يستغل هذه المظاهرات
استغلالا دينيا كما اشرت من قبل وبالتالي
يتصدى اظهر الخطاب الديني المغلوط ودي
قضيه كبيره جدا قضيه الوعي الديني والخطاب
المغلوط التي لس جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
مستغله في الحق لكن الحديث الحديث هنا ليس
عن اراء دينيه الحديث الحديث ابسط بكثير
الحديث يتعلق بوضع بوضع بوضع اقتصادي
باوضاع معيشيه لا اكثر ساعود اليك لكن
اسمح لي ان استمع الى وجهه السيد خليل
العناني فيما فيما قلت تفضل سيد خليل
في البدايه تحيه جلال وتقدير واحترام لكل
المحتجين الذين ظهروا او خرجوا خلال
الايام السبعه الماضيه خاصه بالامس
مطالبين بابسط حقوقهم الدستوريه والمشروع
وتضامنا معهم اظهر اليوم مع الجزيره
مرتديا الزي الذي يرتديه هؤلاء وهو
الجلابيه كما تعرف في مصر اعترافا بحقوقهم
المشروعه التي ليس هناك استجابه لها صراحه
نحن نتحدث عن عرض ومرض اما العرض فهو
الاحتجاج واما المرض فهو الفق القر
والاحتياج هذه الجموع التي خرجت على مدار
الايام الماضيه تطالب بحقوق مشروعه هي
يعني ضحيه سياسات اقتصاديه طاحنه مرت بها
خلال الفتره الماضيه ترجمت في شكل احتقان
وغضب عبر عن نفسه في ظهور وخروج هؤلاء الى
الشوارع والى القرى من اجل ان يطالب حقوق
المشروعه اذا كنا بنتكلم بشكل علمي حقيقي
دعنا ننظر في الارقام على سبيل المثال
وانا ذكرت هذا الامر المره الماضيه على
الجزيره وقلت بانه اذا ضرنا الى خريطه
الفقر في مصر ووضعناها جنب الى جنب الى
خريطه القره المحتج تجد هناك تماهيا الى
حد بعيد بمعنى انه اذا ب بتكلمنا عن
الصعيد الصعيد في مصر حسب الارقام الرسميه
في 57% من خط الفقر يعني خط الفقر الرسمي
في مصر 32% الصعيد يعلو عن ذلك بحوالي 20%
كما جاء في التقرير اسيوط 66% اعلى مستوى
فقر موجود في مصر كلها من من افقر 1000
قريه في مصر موجود عندك 226 قريه في سوهاج
206 قريه في اسيوط 66 قريه في المنيا اذا
اخذنا الجيزه فقط والتي تعتبر ثاني اكبر
محافظه مصريه 9 مليون نسمه تجد انه عفوا
دعني فقط اكمل يا استاذ حسن لو سمحت تجد
انه نسبه الفقر بها 34% اذا نظرت الى
اسباب الخروج هذا هو الذي يجب ان ننظر فيه
عن الاجال السياسي نعم على رغم على رغم
تلك
الارقام نعم على رغم تلك الارقام التي
تقدمها عن ارقام الفقر وغير ذلك ما زال
ضيفنا اسعد هيكل يقول لك ان
الخروج ليس لاهداف او
لاسباب اجتماعيه او لاسباب اقتصاديه او
نتيجه الفقر انما هناك من يحرك هؤلاء من
الخارج ويستغل من
الخارج اولا من حق الاستاذ اسعد ومن حق
النظام في مصر وانصاره واعلامه ان يعتقدوا
ما يشاؤون انا ساتكلم بطريقه ال علميه كي
لا اضيع وقت الجمهور الذي يشاهدنا الان
سارد عليه النقطه بالتفصيل ولكن دعني فقط
اكمل مساله الجيزه من الناحيه من الناحيه
العلميه الجيزه 9 مليون شخص فيها مستوى
الفقر 34% يعني اعلى من مستوى الفقر
القومي ب 2% الجزه تضررت بشكل كبير جدا
خاصه مع امرين رئيسيين الامر الاول هو
هبوط السياحه نعرف ان الجيزه بها مناطق
سياحيه كبيره جدا نتيجه لكوفيد 19 لا تع
هناك السياحه ودخول لمصر فتاثر عائلات
كثيره من هذه الصناعه ثانيا قرارات وقف
البناء المخالف وهي قرارات قد تكون صحيح
لا خلاف على ذلك لكنه تنفيذها كان بطريقه
خاطئه هناك يقال ان 70% من مواد البناء
خاصه للحجر الجيري
او والطوب ياتي من من من الجزه وبالتالي
هناك حاله بطاله فيما يتعلق بمساله
الاخوان المسلمين دعني افند واتحدث عنها
بشكل علمي اولا من الناحيه العلميه المكون
الرئيسي في جماعه الاخوان المسلمين هو
الطبقه الوسطى وهذه الانتفاضه بالاساس هي
انتفاضات فقراء تاتي من الكره واعصابها
الرئيسي الطبقه الفقيره انا اكاد ازعم ان
معظم المنتمين يا جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
الطبقه الوسطى يتفرجوا او لم يخرجوا اما
خوفا واما ياسا واما شماته فيما يخرجوا
الان بقول معظمهم وليس كلهم قد يكون بعضهم
يشارك واذا شاركوا لهم الحق كمصريين بعيدا
عن المواقف السياسيه نمره اثنين طيب اذا
بنتكلم بان سبع سنين في خطاب اعلامي
تشويهي 24 ساعه ل جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
ثم ياتي النظام الان ويقول هم الذين
يحركوا هذا يعني ان الخطاب ان هذا ان هذا
الخطاب فشل فشلا ذريعا يجب ان يحاسب عليه
النظام الحالي في مصر نمره لا اذا ظهرنا
اذا نظرنا الى عمار المحتجين نجد بهم
اطفال كثر هؤلاء لم يكونوا ولدوا حتى
عندما قاموا ثوره يناير بل تعرضوا لغسيل
مخ بن جماعه الاخوان المسلمين جماعه
ارهابيه ورغم ذلك خرجوا وبالتالي كل هذه
المبررات لا تخفي ان هناك مشكله حقيقيه في
مصر ان هناك ازمه اقتصاديه واجتماعيه
طاحنه بغض ننظر عن الوضع السياسي الذي هو
في حد ذاته يعني يثير كثير من الاحتجاجات
لكنه بيتكلم عن البعد الاقتصادي الاجتماعي
حتى للا نحمل المحتجين اكثر م ما يحتملوا
وبالتالي الوضع فعلا من الناحيه العلميه
والناحيه الواقعيه هناك ازمه حقيقيه لا
يجب ان نتف راسنا في الرمال يجب ان نعترف
بها ونواجهها بشجاعه حتى تستقيم الاوضاع س
هيكل سيد اسعد هيكل هل شمعت الارهاب وهدم
الدوله باتت ا مفيده وتؤتي ثمارا كما تريد
السلطات في مصر
حاليا يعني احنا نتحدث عن واقع يعني احنا
ما تحدثنا وقلنا هناك من يحركها او
يستغلها لم نقل في الخارج احنا قنا جماعه
الاخوان بشكل محدد وهي في الخارج وفي
الداخل ايضا في الداخل المصري وقرنا هذه
المظاهرات بالمظاهرات التي حدثت في نهايه
2013 2014 لكن علي لكن الا تعتقد سيد اسعد
يعني حتى دائما هذه المساله تتكرر يعني من
بات الان يصدق ان جماعه الاخوان بمقدورها
ان تحرك تظاهرات وهي التي واجهت ما واجهت
ا كان في السجون او حتى لا يجرؤ احد على
ان يذكر اسم الاخوان الان في مصر بعد
وصمها بالارهاب يعني هل هل من يصدق انها ق
قادره على تحريك كل هذا الشارع معنى ذلك
ان السلطات فشلت فعلا في وضع حد لجماعه
الاخوان المسلمين وانها غير قادره على ضبط
الوضع في
الداخل هو في الحقيقه يعني بنظره التحليل
هي الاخوان نجحت نجاح نوعي في الحقيقه لان
اكسبت مظاهراتها شكل جديد ورجها بشكل
اعلامي جيد وانضم اليها في الحقيقه عدد لا
يستهان به من افراد الشعب العاديين ده
واقعيه وايضا لا احد ينكر حتى ان هناك
اعلاميين مصريين تحدثوا بشكل مباشر
ومشهورين ان هناك مظاهرات واقروا واعترفوا
بها ايضا لن اكون انا ملكيا في سياق سؤالك
المهم انا لست اتحدث عن وجود الاخوان راجع
تسجيل ابراهيم منير مرشد جماعه الاخوان
الاسلام من لندن عبر الجزيره مباشر هو
تحدث الرجل وقال من وراء كل مظاهره تحدث
في مصر سنكون دائما وراء ها هذا كان حديث
ابراهيم فان لست انا ملكا اكثر من الملك
هو الذي قال ذلك بالتالي لا لا احد ينكر
في الحقيقه لا هو الواقع يقول ان جماعه
الاخوان هي التنظيم الوحيد في مصر عبر 80
سنه خبره كبيره ارتفاع الحديث الان يعني
انت انت الان لاول لاول مره ربما يعني كنت
قبل ذلك تتحدث ان هذه بالفعل مظاهرات اناس
تضرروا من القرارات الحكوميه وهم ايضا
فقراء ولديهم مطالب الان انت تتحدث بوضوح
عن ان هؤلاء يحركهم تنظيم الاخوان
المسلمين هل هذه بدايه هل هذه بدايه او
يعني تمهيد لتعاطي مختلف مع هؤلاء خصوصا
على الصعيد الامني بعدما شهدنا مقتل احد
المتظاهرين امس وايضا اعتقالات على مدى
الايام السته
الماضيه هو طبعا المظاهرات دي مهمه جدا
لابد ان ننظر اليها بنظره يعني بدرجه
عاليه من الاهميه هي مقلقه بالتاكيد
للسلطه كما قلت كما قلت انها مظاهرات
نوعيه جديده حتى لو قلنا جماعه الاخوان
لكن مش هننكر ابدا ان في عاديه متضرره
مواطنين عاديين ليس لهم اي اتجاهات سياسيه
متضررين ولابد ان ينظر في مطالبهم لكن ده
كله في مقابل ايه وده الاهم الفكره اللي
عايز اوصلها ايني بس دي فيها استذ حسن ان
هناك ايضا فراغ في المجتمع في التنظيم
المدني الذي يمكن ان يقابل الافكار
المغلوطه التي تسها جماعه الاخوان او
غيرها من الجماعات الخطابات الدينيه
اقصر لا احزاب سياسيه بتخاطب حد ولا رموز
ولا قيادات وطنيه والقلق من وجهه نظري
ياتي من هنا اذا كانت السلطه تستجيب
لمطالب وتسحب قانون او او تقص غرامات كل
هذه حلول مؤقته لكن القلق في فراغ المجتمع
المدني المصري اللي بقى له اكثر من 50 سنه
او اكثر مفرغ من الحياه السياسيه وده ا
اعطى تنامي للجماعات الاخرى الاكثر تشددا
ودي الاشكاليه الكبيره اللي انا قلت تحدثت
عنها في البدايه هل عندك حل لهذه
الاشكاليه سيد خليل العناني
هنا ماذا تهدف السلطات من وراء الحديث
بشكل مستمر عن ان اياد
خارجيه هي التي تحرك هؤلاء الاشاره الى
تنظيم الاخوان المسلمين ثم دخول الازهر
على الخط واعتبار ان هذا
يهدم
الدوله هل هذا مقدمه لشيء ما
الاسب لا يعني احنا الدوله المصريه بشكل
عام او النظام الحالي تحليا في مصر هو
يعيش على نظريه المؤامره داخليا وخارجيا
هو في حاله تعبئه عامه وحشد عام للمجتمع
المصري منذ سبع سنوات على الاعتبار انه
يحارب عدوا كان محتملا ثم اصبح عدوا
واقعيا ولس هذه السياسات تنتج بالفعل
اعداء لكنهم اعداء ضحايا بالاساس للفقر
وضحايا للبطاله وضحايا لكل هذه المسائل
الان لا يزال هناك اصرار على الانكار ولا
يزال هناك اصرار طبعا بدانا في البدايات
قبل حوالي اسبوع انه ليس هناك احتجاجات ثم
انتقلنا انها احتجاجات محدوده ثم انتقلنا
الا طب ستمع على مطالب الناس طيب اذا كان
بالفعل الذي يحرك هؤلاء الاوان المسلمين
لماذا ارسلت لهم الدوله قبل حوالي اربعه
ايام احد اعضاء مجلس الشعب يتفاوض معهم
اذا كانت بالفعل جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
تستغل هذه الاحتجاجات وقد يكون هذا صحيح
لان هناك صراع سياسي طاحن بينها وبين
النظام في مصر لاسباب ليس هناك مجال
للدخول فيها فليقم النظام في مصر الان
بالاستجابه لهذه المطالب كي يسحب هذه
الذعيه من جماعه الاخوان المسلمين وكي
ينفي عن هلا المتظاهرين هذه المساله
وبالتالي انت لديك يعني وضع سياسي متازم
في مصر ليس هناك اجابه حقيقيه يعني اجابه
حقيقيه على الاسئله الرئيسيه فيه كما قلت
قبل قليل وحتى الخطاب الرسمي للدوله يعني
قال السيسي قبل فتره احنا فقرا قوي وقال
انا مش قادر اديك يعني هو بنفسي اعترف ان
هناك حاله فقر في مصر وانه في كل خطاباته
يؤكد على انه ليس انه ليس هناك موارد في
مصر ل ربنا
يدي مليار جنيه هذا الكلام يفترض بهذا
الكلام ان يكون لصالح الرئيس السيسي يعني
عندما يقول نعم نحن فقراء هو يعترف
بالواقع الاقتصادي القائم في
البلد وهل وظيفه السياسي الذي يقود دوله
ان يعترف فقط دون ان يقدم سياسات يعالج
بها هذه المساله لم يكن يستطع على ذلك
فليترك السلطه هذا يعني بكل بساطه لكنه
للاسف الشديد يعترف ولا يقوم باي شيء بل
بالعكس ودعني فقط اعطيك ايضا رقم اخر يؤكد
ان هناك مشكله حقيقيه في توزيع الموارد في
مصر قبل حوالي اسبوع ا رئيس البنك المركزي
طارق عامر قال بان دخل مصر منذ ست سنوات
يعني منذ تولي السيسي للسلطه وحتى الان
431 مليار دولار يعني حوالي نصف تريليون
جنيه السؤال الرئيسي اين ذهبت هذه الاموال
كيف تم انفاقها هل هناك محاسبه على انفاق
هذه الاموال ما هي الاولويات التي تنفق
هذه فيها ه هذه الاموال هل الصعيد تحديدا
هل الفقراء هل الكر يا استاذ حسن نحن
لدينا في مصر 5660 قريه على الاقل للتهم
يعاني فقرا وفقرا مدقعا يعني ليس هناك
حاجات اساسيه
كالصحيح كالمياه النظيفه تعاني مستشفياتها
من من الاهمال حاله يعني تفشي الكورونا
كان بسبب هذه المساله وبالتالي هناك
اعتراف بالمشكله وعدم قدره على هذا يعني
ان هناك فشلا ذريعا يفترض ويتطلب من
السلطه اما ان تجد حلول واقعيه لها واما
تتنازل عن السلطه وتترك المجال الاخرين
يحاولون
ويجربوا شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور خليل العناني
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في معهد الدوحه
للدراسات العليا واشكر اسعد هيكل المحامي
والمحلل السياسي كان معنا من القاهره عبر
الانترنت في المحطات التاليه مشاهدينا
تتناول ليى الشيخ لي ما بعد اعتذار مصطفى
اديب عن الاستمرار في مساعي تشكيل حكومه
لبنانيه جديده